hey everybody DC films is starting
things out with a bang in 2018 they just
announced what's going on behind the
scenes and I'll give an update on the
really big films like they're getting
ready to cast their Nightwing there's
even a reign of the Superman film that
they're getting ready to release in 2019
so just a whole bunch of stuff is going
on behind the scenes Geoff Johns
actually posted this image just you know
welcome aboard Walter talking about the
new person that they brought in to run
DC films so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's gonna be more comic
book movies happening this year than
we've ever had in a single year it's
gonna be crazy so you're asking what
does Jeff John's statement mean did he
get fired is he not in charge of DC
films anymore what happened is his last
year John burg and Geoff Johns were sort
of appointed Co heads in a way really
John Berg was in charge of DC films but
that was well Justice League was
happening it along with Suicide Squad
the last couple of films didn't make the
amount of money that Warner Brothers as
a company wanted it to make so naturally
in any business not just the film
business that means of regime change so
they brought in someone called Walter
Hamada who's basically the person that
was responsible for the it movie the
conjuring franchise some of that has a
proven track record with big films like
this and is really good at spotting
quality like you find a good idea let's
turn that into a movie and that's what
you need for DC films if you're not sure
what geoff johns is doing he's actually
still one of the co riders on the Shazam
movie they just rolled into production
like Zachary Levi and the director just
showed up in Canada like all right let's
start filming this movie let's get going
Deuteronomy to make a little movie
coaches say society
so before I think the idea was is they
had a little more authority in dealing
with the directors but you know it's a
really weird situation behind the scenes
because if a powerful enough director
like zack snyder or joss whedon comes in
it's a lot harder for people like jeff
jones to give them notes and say you
know what maybe we do the film this way
suffice to say whatever happened behind
the scenes if things don't go well and
there's this much money involved
typically what happens is is the board
gets wiped clean and a new regime comes
in which is what has happened now
obviously you're asking they announced a
whole bunch of films like there's a
Deathstroke film that we learned about
there's a couple different harley quinn
movies there's a flashpoint movie are
they still making those what's happening
with the new Batman franchise is Ben
Affleck sticking around the only things
that we know is that they do plan to
release a Green Lantern Corps movie
Batgirl
the new Batman franchise the Nightwing
movie another Man of Steel movie in
Wonder Woman to of course probably the
most solid thing that they have going
right now is that next Wonder Woman
movie because the first one was so
successful they actually just gave an
interview about Wonder Woman to talking
a little bit about how it's gonna be
different here's this a clip from that I
couldn't remove the weird audio track on
this but it's a pretty short clip and I
love what we're working on so I was like
we can do anything we want with this
character in this world right now so
we're actually making a totally
different film with a lot of the same
similar like things that we love but
it's a it's its own movie completely so
it's not to anything to us yeah to us
it's an entirely new adventure together
that were jealous when I whenever I hear
Wonder Woman - I'm like
[Music]
I know there were a lot of questions
about will Linda Carter the original
Wonder Woman on television will she make
a cameo in this one Linda is one of the
dearest people to us has been a great
mentor and dear friend and we actually
desperately tried to get her in the
first one and we had the scheduling
thing that it couldn't work so she's
always been a part of our Wonder Woman
when we get some more actual details
about that movie I'll do a separate
video about that but with a lot of those
films that don't have directors or don't
have scripts they're just gonna wait til
they have the right material which is
what this new person that Jeff Jones is
congratulating is going to decide like
when he decides that there's the right
material they'll move forward with the
film so if you don't see Superman man of
tomorrow for three or four more years
it's just because they haven't found the
right material yet Henry Cavill is still
sticking around he talked about it a
little bit at that convention I put a
clip of it in another video I'll play it
in a second but geoff johns also had
this really cool explainer for what
happens when you have a list of say like
20 films that could possibly get made
how do you decide which one comes next
so these are those clips
[Music]
how do you think you should get back how
would you like and this is one thing I
learned about development they had 20
different projects on this list on the
wall in development like this one of
Dick's next movie I remember they said
dick sex movies one of these 20 projects
oh cool and then one day conspiracies
theory came in Mel Gibson one to do it
and that was his next movie I go what
about these 20 oh they're gonna get
below it now so it took the jump right
away and I'm like okay this is how it
works
so as Jeff John says there are
situations where even if you have twenty
really solid looking films on a schedule
if the right actor in the right director
come in and say we want to make this
film BAM that is the next film that
you're making best example of that would
be if Christian Bale came to Warner
Brothers and said you know what I really
like Batman Beyond I want to do old
Bruce Wayne let's either do Terry
McGinnis or we can do Damian Wayne and
he can be the Batman beyond character so
it's all about the right director the
right actor the right script if that
just walks up on their doorstep it
doesn't matter which films they're
planning on making like if they had a
Gotham City sirens movie that was ready
to go but Christian Bale came along for
Batman Beyond they'd be like oh hell
yeah we're doing Batman Beyond next that
other film that we were getting ready to
do that's getting bumped down the line
will still make all these other films
it's just the rule of business that when
a big opportunity like that comes along
they have to do that first so like if
Leonardo DiCaprio wants to do a DC film
and Martin Scorsese is like you know
what let's do a Joker film it doesn't
matter what Jared Leto thinks they will
do that film but for the most part the
biggest films that they've announced
that they're doing like the Green
Lantern Corps movie the Wonder Woman
franchise Batgirl the Nightwing movie
the new Batman franchise that's all
still happening the big question now is
just when it's going to come so I know
everybody wants to hear release day it's
like when is the flashpoint movie going
to happen are they going to use that to
change some of the continuity to explain
if some of the actors want to come or go
if Ben Affleck doesn't want to do that
new Batman film so upside downside Ben
Affleck is still flip-flopping on
continuing to be the Batman character
I've already made a couple films about
their plans for the flashpoint movie Ben
Affleck will return for at least one
more film he's under contract for five
films and he's only done three
of those appearances so he has to come
back for at least one but I think if he
really wants to go then Warner Brothers
will let him go so that when they get to
Matt Reeves film they could just start
completely fresh with a new actor so we
can talk about that if they make some
announcements but as for right now
there's no definitive answer about who's
going to be the Batman of Matt Reeves
Batman movie I don't think we're gonna
hear about that for a while maybe after
flashpoint hits theaters well let me
know in the comments what do you guys
think about all the big changes that are
going on I know everybody wants to hear
about Nightwing because they really will
cast the actor in the next couple of
months we'll find out who's playing him
in the movie universe but obviously we
have our TV Nightwing that's going to be
on the Titans TV show he'll start out
Robin then slowly become the Nightwing
character over the course of that show
so we'll talk more about Titan stuff
when they drop a new teaser but while
you wait for everything click here to
learn about the big villain for season 1
of Titans and click here for that brand
new black panther trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
happy new year